Tim Ferriss: Hello, boys and girls, ladies
and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode of The Tim Ferriss
Show.
I'm going to keep my preamble short so we
can get to the meat of this conversation with
my guest today, Aryeh B. Bourkoff.
He is the chairman and CEO of LionTree, an
independent investment and merchant bank,
advising and investing in transformational
CEOs and the companies they lead.
Aryeh founded LionTree in 2012, during a time
of unprecedented disruption.
And since then, LionTree has supported an
expanding number of industries as they capture
opportunity in an evolving digital economy.
We're going to touch on a lot of those points.
Aryeh is also the founder of Kindred Media,
a digital media and podcasting company powered
by LionTree, and serves on the boards of Yahoo
and Carnegie Hall.
Before founding LionTree, Aryeh spent 13 years
at UBS, closing his tenure as vice chairman
and head of Americas Investment Banking.
Before UBS, Aryeh was a high-yield research
analyst and ranked as the number one cable
and satellite analyst by Institutional Investor
for seven consecutive years.
Aryeh is a graduate of the University of California
at San Diego and resides in New York City
with his family.
You can find LionTree at liontree.com.
And on Instagram you can find a number of
accounts @aryehbourkoff.
That's spelled A-R-Y-E-H B-O-U-R-K-O-F-F,
@liontree_llc and @kindredpodcast.
Aryeh, welcome to the show.
Nice to see you.
Aryeh Bourkoff: Thanks, Tim.
Great to see you.
Thanks for having me.
Tim Ferriss: Of course.
Of course.
I've been looking forward to this.
And I wanted to start with, actually, a mention
in your bio.
So, ranked as the number one cable and satellite
analyst by Institutional Investor for seven
consecutive years.
What makes a good analyst?
Or what made you a good analyst, and what
are common mistakes that analysts make?
Aryeh Bourkoff: Well, it takes me back.
A career has different chapters to it.
Right?
I actually think those chapters should be
related to one another and foundational in
nature.
But I don't like to hover in one place for
too often, and I also don't like to think
about the zero-sum game.
So things I'm doing today have no relationship
with things I did before.
But I'm glad you brought up this analyst job,
because I think a lot of people forget about
that part of my life.
But it was so core in training and also in
the relationships and the understanding of
how to be not only a good purveyor of companies,
but also of my own emotional stability, I
would say.
And so, the way I would say that is, "analyst"
is often thrown around, but it could be like
a therapist, an analyst, but in this case
a research analyst, which I was, as someone
that really looked at securities or stocks
or bonds in a particular industry.
So for me, the industries were always media,
cable, telecoms, technology, consumer-driven
companies.
And at first, I looked at those companies
from a bond perspective, junk bonds, high-yield
bonds, and then equities, stocks.
And covering those stocks in those same industries
allowed me to, ultimately, get to a goal of
helping investors make money with those recommendations.
Now, how you do that is understanding the
company, its fundamental picture and, ultimately,
where it's going in the future, because everything
today should be understood, and everything
tomorrow should have a lot of uncertainty
around it.
So pattern recognition, how to predict the
future, is the first thing that you really
are supposed to be learning as an analyst,
in order to help inform the masses of which
investments to make.
But then, the emotional stability part of
it comes into play, when you get out in front
of everybody and say, with some boldness and
some prose and some analysis, "Here's my view.
I think I'm right."
More often than not, you're wrong.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Aryeh Bourkoff: And it's like watching two
kids in a schoolyard, when you were growing
up, getting into an argument.
And you watched one of them clearly lose that
argument and then count down until you saw
that they recognized, that they would have
the confidence to admit that they lost the
argument.
And there's always a lag.
It could be 10 seconds.
It could be weeks, could be years.
And that's all about capitulation.
And so the first thing I learned was when
I was wrong, and I thought that I would be
right, to quickly recognize that I didn't
have anything that was that interesting or
different to say in front of everybody.
And by doing that, it was very embarrassing.
And these could even be minor things.
But it built so much credibility later that
when you are right, it counted so much more
and for so much more.
And then it built your own self-confidence
that you really did have something.
And then, if you're really lucky... and that's
where the rankings coming into play...
when you say something that's different than
the masses, and you have the confidence to
say, going against the grain, to predict the
future, then the markets will go with you.
The investors will go with you.
People will be profitable based on your recommendation.
People will make money based on what you say,
and you build a reputation.
And that was a process.
Tim Ferriss: This raises a number of secondary
questions.
Well, the first, just for clarification, when
you're talking about taking a public stance
and promoting or publishing an opinion, what
form does that take?
Is it a ranking system?
Is it a general sort of binary buy or sell
recommendation?
Just for folks who are listening, to have
a more discrete understanding of what that
opinion looks like.
What form does that take?
Aryeh Bourkoff: Oh, it has to be a published
report that has to have an initiation report.
It could be a report on the industry.
So it has to have some perspective, some thematic,
and within it, some specific company recommendation.
So let's just say I want to write a report
on the movie studios.
And then within that report I would say, "Here's
my view of the movie studios" and specifically
my recommendation on Disney, and Warner Brothers,
and Viacom at the time, and Fox at the time.
And then you said, "Within these, these are
my recommendations.
Buy, hold, sell," and supportive documents.
And then, because you knew that no one would
actually go and read a hundred pages, you'd
have to summarize it in a perfectly synthesized,
four-bullet point cover page.
And before any of that stuff happened, you
have to go through internal processes to defend
your arguments, where people internally have
the right to say, "We don't really think that
works."
But more often than not, they would let you
go, and let the public be your ultimate judge
and juror, because that public embarrassment
would be much, far more damaging to you, and
far more self-correcting, than anything they
would say internally.
But they have, obviously, institutions to
protect.
But those documents were full of analysis
and thematics and context, both context of
the here and now, and the past versus the
future.
But the ultimate goal is predicting the future.
If I said to you, Tim, today is, let's say
Monday.
And by Friday, I was going to tell you, based
on a certain pattern recognition, what was
going to happen to these stocks, based on
my analysis, or, maybe better, a year from
now, and you believed me because of my credibility
and our relationship, and we had a track record
together, and that conviction level was high,
then you may invest, just based on my word.
But at the beginning, you'd say, "I need to
do my own research.
I'm going to read your report.
Then I'm going to check it with other people's
reports, my own conviction level."
Maybe I'm a counter-indicator sometimes.
But hopefully, you are the indicator.
And then, obviously over time, if you're right,
more often than not, you just start investing
for yourself.
You may not give it to everybody else as a
service.
That's the motion of a career, right?
Tim Ferriss: That is your evolution.
It's not always evolution.
Right?
Playing with your own chips, and taking that
responsibility to make direct bets in that
way, is not a leap that everyone makes.
And I want to take a step back for a second
just to read a fantastic headline.
This is a piece from The Hollywood Reporter.
So, "How Aryeh Bourkoff Became Media’s Hottest
Dealmaker."
So some of the groundwork that we're laying
right now is going to lead into that.
But I wanted to mention that because it is
an exceptional piece.
I thought it was a very entertaining piece
also that people should check out.
Let's rewind to Alan Ginsberg.
Not the poet.
Different Alan Ginsberg.
Who is Alan Ginsberg, and what are some of
the lessons that you learned from him?
Aryeh Bourkoff: Alan Ginsberg gave me a shot.
And he was a mentor and the person that first
hired me into this thing called Wall Street
in New York.
And remember, I came from California, had
no reason to be anywhere near this industry
or Wall Street, didn't know anything, really,
of substance, coming out of university, except
what everyone else knows, which is how to
communicate, look for a job, maybe how to
write a little bit.
Other people maybe have much more vocational
expertise in engineering and medicine than
I did.
I was a generalist, coming out.
So, coming to New York, didn't know a soul,
and basically put resumes under windshield
wipers, so like, yeah, "Here's my flyer.
I have an interest in being here.
I'll hustle, and I'll earn it."
And then you have to convince people to give
you a shot.
And Alan Ginsberg gave me that first shot.
And when I interviewed with Alan, who himself
was, and is...
We're still in touch... a creative person
in finance, because Alan's background, even
though he was a lawyer and a financier and
so on, he also wrote for Rolling Stone magazine.
He liked writing.
He liked the way the world worked.
And he wasn't a traditional person you think
of as a Gordon Gekko, Wall Street type.
And so maybe that's why we took an interest
in each other, because we talked about how
the world worked, and he gave me a chance.
And so Alan hired me, and he said, I remember
he said, "You're going to be the first person
that works for us in the high-yield bond group
at Smith Barney."
And Alan ran the Smith Barney research group,
having come from Bear Stearns before that.
And I think before that, he was immediately
at Drexel Burnham in Los Angeles, the Michael
Milken high-yield bond shop.
And I said, "Okay, great.
I'm going to work for you.
What do I do?"
And he said, "You're going to help me cover
the industries that I focus on."
And I said, "Which of those industries?"
And he said, "It's media.
It's telecom.
It's technology.
It's food.
And it's restaurants."
And I said, "I have no idea what you just
said, but I like to eat and like to go out
to eat in restaurants.
So that sounds good."
Eventually those fell away, and I kept going
with those media and communications and technology
industries from day one.
And then I just decided to get that competitive
streak to be better than the rest and to work
at it.
And I eventually got the bug.
But I remember thinking to myself, watching
him in action, "I will never be able to be
as good at communicating as he is or as good
at analyzing companies as he is."
And you just kept going at it until you eventually
get the groove.
Tim Ferriss: So, two questions related to
what you just shared.
The first is, why go from California, backpack
in hand, to Wall Street and even make the
attempt?
What was the draw or the reasoning there?
And then secondly, why do you think Alan gave
you a shot?
Why would he say yes?
Why would he take that ostensible risk?
Aryeh Bourkoff: I was in California at the
University of California in San Diego, as
you mentioned, and I knew, as I was graduating,
that I wanted to get into the center of finance.
I didn't want to stay in the periphery.
If you're going to go into an industry, go
to the heart of it.
Don't plan around the edges.
Tim Ferriss: Why the interest in finance,
also?
Why finance at all?
Aryeh Bourkoff: This is the way I described
it to my parents, who are academics and looked
at finance, I could tell, in a disdainful
way, like, "That's not a way to live your
life."
Maybe a lot of your listeners think the same
way.
And I thought to myself, "Okay, I have to
present this to them."
And I remember going to travel to see my mother,
and I said, "I'm going to go into finance,
and this is the way that I think it's a worthwhile
way to live your life," because they were
academics and professors and so on.
And I said, "Entrepreneurs, people have hopes
and dreams that sometimes take the shape and
form of businesses.
And those businesses need money, capital,
to see the light of day, to realize their
dreams.
And that's finance.
And if I can play a role in helping those
individuals get capital and have their dreams
realized, that is a worthwhile life to live."
Sounds like a good pitch, right?
But I don't know if I really believe-
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Sounds like a good pitch.
Aryeh Bourkoff: Good pitch, but I mean, that
landed well, and I mean, I got the blessing.
Plus I was rehearsing, probably practicing
my interviews.
But that's really what I believed and believe
to this day.
And that's kind of what makes it interesting.
You see the energy in someone else, that you're
able to recast a problem as a solution that
is based on someone's real idea.
And it's not just about moving pieces around.
It's about creating something new.
And I think that that wasn't enough.
It was enough for my parents, but it wasn't
enough in New York, because a lot of people
have that pitch, I think.
Almost like I remember when I was in the college,
I went to some of these parties, and you would
walk in with your friends, and the vibe would
happen.
And I remember walking in with one of my college
friends.
And he couldn't get any women to pay attention
to him.
I remember he said to me one day, he goes,
"I don't know.
My mother always says I'm attractive."
I remember thinking to myself, "I passed the
test with my mother about my pitch, but when
I got to New York, it didn't really land as
well."
It may have landed, but it was in competition
with a lot of other people.
And so it took me about four months in New
York to get to Alan, because the day I moved
to New York was because of a job interview.
And I thought I hit the jackpot, one of one.
The day I graduated was a Sunday, and I think
Monday or Tuesday, I had an interview set
up with a guy named Paul Ting...
I don't mind saying it now.
He's probably out there somewhere at Oppenheimer...
And he covered the oil and gas industry.
The oil and gas industry.
I told myself I wasn't going to choose the
industry.
Whoever hired me first, I would just be loyal
to that industry for the rest of my life —
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Aryeh Bourkoff: — and I could build a specialty.
And so I went and, incredibly, I got this
interview, and I had a meeting like this day,
day two in New York, downtown, the big city.
It was 1995.
Yeah, 1995.
And I thought the interview was great, and
I was going to be a research analyst working
for Paul Ting, oil and gas, Oppenheimer.
And at the end, I was starting to strut out
of the office and said, "Okay.
Next step?
When do I start?"
This is like the same interview I had with
my mother.
It's landing well.
And he goes, "By the way, one more question."
He goes, "Do you know the programming language
Visual Basic?"
Like, "C+, Visual Basic."
And I said, "No."
And he said, "Well, I kind of need you to
know that if you're going to be on the team."
These days, they call it a doorknob negotiation.
On the way out, as you're holding the doorknob
and turn back and say, "By the way, one more
thing."
That's the whole negotiation, at the doorknob.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Right.
Aryeh Bourkoff: So, that's what he said.
"By the way, one more thing.
Do you know Visual Basic?"
I said, "No."
And he said, "Well, you're going to need to
know that for me to hire you."
I said, "Well, what if I learn it and master
it?
Will then you hire me?"
He goes, "Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Then we're good."
That's New York City.
I was like, "Great."
I left, bought Visual Basic for Dummies, bought
a laptop, drained my account, and got subletted
an apartment, started learning the thing.
Two weeks later, I felt comfortable.
"This is the world as it should be."
Called them.
And I never got a return phone call.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, man.
Aryeh Bourkoff: And I was like, "Well, what
do I do now?
What I do now?"
By the way, while I was at UBS in a senior
position in research, I did see across the
tape, probably, I don't know, 15 years later,
that we hired a guy named Paul Ting at Oppenheimer
to do oil and gas for UBS, when I was there
doing media.
And I waited till he started, and I went down
the hallway.
I knocked on door.
I said, "By the way, Paul, you may or may
not remember me.
I want to welcome you to UBS."
At this point, I was an established senior
person doing media stocks, really well-established
at UBS.
And I said, "I just want to welcome you.
And I want to tell you that I mastered that
fucking Visual Basic programming language
and I wish you luck here, buddy."
You're really putting on the other side one
of your philosophies in life.
"The toe you step on today could be connected
to the ass you're going to kiss tomorrow."
File away.
And I still know him.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, good.
Good mantra.
Aryeh Bourkoff: So yeah.
Four months later, left in New York, I became
a professional job seeker.
And I would basically walk to different buildings
that looked like hitter buildings.
And I looked at the directory at the basement,
at the lobby level, looked for what looked
like Wall Street firms, the ones I recognized,
obviously.
And then others I didn't recognize.
And I would go up.
This is pre-9/11.
They didn't check IDs.
I would go up to the HR floor, and I would
hand in my resume.
And I would choose a different location in
Manhattan every week to tackle.
The downtown, the midtown.
And then one day, I stumbled upon Smith Barney.
It was still on Greenwich Street downtown,
right across from the Greenwich Hotel.
This is now an amazing, hot area.
Back then, it was away from Wall Street and
away from the action.
And Karine Krenik, to her credit, since I'm
naming names, was the HR person that let me
through the door and gave me a shot, wherever
she is, and introduced me to Alan Ginsberg.
And by that point, I was pretty good on the
pitch and also self-corrective, knowing what
didn't land and what landed.
And Alan gave me a shot.
And I think he liked the hustle.
He liked the hustle, liked the background
probably, and also a little bit of luck.
But he also called me out for bullshit.
The proverbial question in interview is, "What's
your weakness?"
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Aryeh Bourkoff: Remember, that's when I was
practiced.
So I said, "My penmanship."
And I thought that was pretty clever.
And he said, "That's a bullshit answer."
He went, "Try again."
So then I had to figure that out.
I stumbled through it.
But we both chuckled.
And I forgot what I said exactly, but I'm
sure I said something that was more sensitive.
But he called me out on it.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Amazing.
Well, it seems like perhaps a blessing in
disguise, life saving you from what you wanted
with Paul and the oil and gas.
But who's to say, I suppose, in retrospect?
I want to take a closer look at Alan teaching
you how the world worked.
And I'm looking at a Kindred Media piece on
Medium, and there's a mention of Alan.
And I'll just read part of it, which is, "One
day, Ginsburg asked him..." (that's asking
you) "...if he read the paper.
'Thinking, "What deal did I miss?
What happened?
Did I miss a number?"'
Aryeh reminisced.
'[Ginsburg] goes, "No, no, no, no.
Forget the numbers.
The Opera House burned down in Florence.
You didn’t read that?"
And I said, "I didn’t even think to read
that."
And he said, "You’re going to have to be
a little more open-minded about this."'"
And the reason I bring this up is that, observing
you in person, and also doing research in
preparation for this conversation, you, more
than almost anyone I've ever met, tie together
many, many, many, many disparate worlds.
And you seem to have pattern recognition not
just in one sector, but across sectors.
Was there any other world educating that comes
to mind, and that could be through direct
teaching or osmosis, observation, that came
to you from Alan or other mentors?
Aryeh Bourkoff: Yeah.
I appreciate that you said that because it's
much easier in life to stay in a box and a
blanket, a compartment of the whole ecosystem.
And by the way, there are places for people
to be in those boxes and to thrive in those
boxes.
When you start to move outside of that box,
or in the corners of that box, or the edge
of that box, or outside of that box, and draw
outside the line, so to speak, it is a beautiful
place to live.
And it is also a dangerous place to live because
it's full of unknowns and uncomfortable, maybe
groundbreaking, things.
It reminds me of another philosophical line
of, "Conventional thinking is typically right,
but seldom profitable."
Tim Ferriss: That's great.
Aryeh Bourkoff: It feels good to think like
everybody else and to be moving with a herd,
but you're not going to make a difference.
You could be wrong, but you may never really
be right in an outsized way if you don't really
stretch into the unknown.
And some people are not comfortable with that.
But where do I get that from?
I mean, I get that from everybody, but it
really goes back to self-work.
Ultimately, you have to have a strong core
to be able to do that, because if you just
move with the wind outside the box, then you
don't really know who you are.
Tim Ferriss: So, just to interrupt for a second,
so, by having clarity on that core or a solid
core, is that...
If you wouldn't mind, sorry to interrupt,
but just expanding that for a second, is that
a core set of values, a clear idea of what
you will or will not do, so that you don't
end up conforming to whatever winds happen
to be blowing at that moment?
Aryeh Bourkoff: Yes.
Yes.
It reminds me of the scene in Raiders of the
Lost Ark, that last scene where the evil spirit
comes into the warehouse, and Indiana Jones
and his compatriot or his partner, his girlfriend,
whatever...
At that point, they're all intermingled...
are hanging on to a foundational pole with
their eyes closed.
But yet this spirit comes in and completely
destroys everything else and kills everyone's
faces.
And it's a horror scene.
Right?
But they survive.
And they survive because of hanging on to
this pole, hanging on to each other, and keeping
their eyes closed, and just hoping their way
through it.
And obviously, the metaphor is they're good,
and everyone else is evil, and that spirit
recognizes it.
Right?
But I think about that like, you have to hold
on to a few poles.
You can't just be floating around.
You have to have a few poles of foundational
strength that you believe in, that are making
up your core.
And those are tried and true, but at the same
time, that allows you to be curious, self-adjusting,
self-corrective, migrational around other
areas, and being comfortable with many different
types of people that are not like you at all
because you have that core, and that creates
a very balanced and textured life and existence,
and a way to build pattern recognition and
perspective that most people would be locked
in pursuing.
And by the way, I'm blocked in my own way
too.
Everyone has certain blocks.
But the more of that exercise that you can
do the more of a perspective you can get of
where the world's going and where it looks
like to be different cultures while you're
living in your own foundational strength and
values.
And I think to me, that all goes back to the
basic foundation of self-awareness, self-work,
self-correction, self-growth.
And once you have that, you're a member of
society that's valuable.
And then you look for that in others and run
away from people that are ignorant or biased
or morose or also maybe a nicer version of
that is just want to go with the flow everywhere
and don't feel comfortable with some out of
the box thinking because it's threatening
to those foundational values.
A way to say that from a finance perspective
is when I was a research analyst, I wouldn't
feel comfortable putting a buy recommendation
on a stock before I'd hit the send button
until I both felt the conviction of the buy
and the rejection of the sell.
So I had to live with the sell recommendation
inside of me first for a little while to see
if it felt comfortable or uncomfortable and
let it in.
Let the poison inside for a while.
If that felt too comfortable for me, I couldn't
in good conscience go to the buy.
So I had to have a buy and the rejection of
the sell because the buy to me could have
been a passive recommendation, not an active
recommendation.
So you have to ask yourself, are you comfortable
going into a controversial scenario or do
you want to just live in the non-controversial?
Tim Ferriss: One more question on this core.
Is this a, let's just call it a general imperturbability
or a solidity that was more a felt sense for
you?
Or was it something that you, at that time,
codified in some way where you're like, "I
prioritize these five things" or "I resolve
to follow these following values?"
Was it codified or was it more of a felt sense
of stability and solidity for you at that
time?
Aryeh Bourkoff: Excellent question.
Both, they're interrelated.
So the first time I remember feeling that
sensibility was probably in grade school being
popular kid with the friends, everything.
Not an outcast with the group, but a little
bit different and feeling inside a little
different.
And then the question is, do you feel bad
about being different or does it start to
empower you or both?
And I, felt like, well, let's test it out.
And I remember thinking, I am very happily
situated where I was in eighth grade, but
let me leave that to go to a new ninth grade
school that was an unknown, away from all
my friends.
And let's see if friends were the thing that
made me feel great or the inside was the thing
that I could apply to new friends and keep
that train going.
And I chose to apply it to the unknown and
chose a brand new place and left behind what
I had before.
Now, I wouldn't do that with family or a very
close relationship, but I had felt very comfortable
doing it with the environment I was in, to
get myself in a new environment and knowing
that it's me that can adjust and apply my
skills to different areas and not the environment
around me that defined who I was.
I could be more proactive defining environments
versus having it defined for me.
I remember that back then and it's happened
a few different times in my life, whether
it's moving different places or feeling comfortable,
I always say I feel comfortable everywhere
but belong nowhere.
That's a geographic comment.
And that's true by and large.
But I also have done that in my careers where
I feel after a certain amount of time in one
area, move.
Take these strong parts of what it's applicable,
maybe the industry knowledge into new areas,
but learn areas then I didn't know before.
And see if you can reconcile those two things.
And then that builds that core with the unknown
together.
That's a life of curiosity and creativity,
but also life of foundation and strength and
contribution on the other hand.
And that I call that the gray area, like you
are comfortable in the gray area.
And I feel like that's a competitive advantage
for me.
I can hang out in that gray area longer than
most people in the world, very comfortably,
until I see the optimal scenario to pass on.
MIDROLL
Tim Ferriss: Let's talk about perhaps that
gray area, and maybe misapplying that term
to what I'm going to ask.
But this relates to a story you told me last
winter, and if you don't want to discuss this,
I can imagine it's sensitive, but we can also
cut it afterwards.
But I think it came about because of the title
of my first book, 4-Hour Workweek, and someone
said, "Oh, you should talk to Aryeh because
that is probably not going to be a driving
philosophy," or something along those lines.
Although I do think we have some similarities
as well in terms of per hour output and thinking
about various things.
And you told me a story, I'm going to get
some of the details wrong, so I'd like you
to correct it, but about at one point realizing
that many meetings were being declined because
your calendar was full and then deciding to
take an entire year to block out every Wednesday,
I can't remember, from six to 10:00 p.m. or
something, to take all of those overflow meetings
that were being canceled.
Could you retell that story if you wouldn't
mind?
Aryeh Bourkoff: Sure, so it all starts with
the concept of rejecting constraints on one
hand.
On the other hand, problem solving, which
is probably one of these terms that are thrown
around so many times, problem solving.
I'm a problem solver.
I run a company on solving problems.
And there's probably like, but who actually
does that?
I mean, put yourself in a situation where
you actually solve a problem that seems insurmountable.
And so one of those problems were time.
I don't have enough time.
Time being the constraint, just tackle solving
that problem because everyone just talks about
that all the time.
And the other part of the story is the passive
or active conscious or subconscious deprioritization
of people that are, let's say, not as important
to you as your kindness team wants them to
be.
But you're really not going to put them on
your calendar in the prime spots.
So you deprioritize them.
And even if you are prioritizing them in your
mind and your heart and your body and your
soul, your office will deprioritize them for
you.
And people have become an expert at these
things right.
Now over time, you build a luxury in life
of being able to do that and be more selective
because as you mature, you want to spend time
with only things that are essential.
Maybe you're running out of time.
But when you first start a company, and we
first started a company with relationships
at its core and with reputation, that's really
important to define the company, the concept
of rejecting people or those relationships
in any form, is out of the question.
So what would happen at the beginning of the
firm some 10 years ago was, I recognize that
I was a funnel.
People would want to figure out what was going
on at one point in time.
There are very few things in your life that
light up all your contacts at one time.
Let's say your wedding, your funeral, God
forbid, maybe a big job movement, a big news
item.
Imagine, and all of a sudden your phone lights
up.
But most of the time it just smooths out.
Certain people won't care about different
things.
When you start a company, it will light up
everything on your contacts, hopefully.
Or if it doesn't, you have a bigger problem.
And so this was a company starting, based
on all of the relationships in my contact
base and a place to put them and to cultivate
them, to build a skyscraper.
But at the beginning it was just me and the
relationships and an assistant.
And so I started to get wind of the fact that
certain people couldn't get on my calendar,
which is obviously natural because you can't
put every single one of your contacts on your
calendar at the moment you announce a new
company, even if it's a few weeks out, people
are going to say, "Sorry, I can't make it."
But imagine how that feels for somebody else.
I want to support this new LionTree venture
and what Aryeh is doing, but you can't see
me.
What a horrible way to start a company.
I don't care who you are.
So after a while of reading and hearing people
sending me notes or emails, I recognize that
there are certain category of people that
they were, because obviously the office knew
enough to give them credit to prioritize the
Tim Ferrisses of the world right away, or
they maybe prioritize things that would be
immediately like dollars oriented or transactional,
which is also not the philosophy of the company,
but they wouldn't prioritize things that would
be career advice or people that wanted to
work with the company as a vendor or business
partner, things like that, that they wouldn't
even know, but I would know.
So I brought my assistant into the office
and I said, "So what is this thing we're rejecting
people?"
They said, "Well, you don't have time."
I said, "Yeah, but you get paid to say yes.
I can say no."
That's the job of the assistant to figure
out a way to say yes.
And they said, "But yes, but Aryeh, you don't
have the time on your calendar."
And I said, "Well, that's the question.
Let's figure out the problem solving of time
now.
What if I created a whole extra day in the
week?
Would that unlock the potential for filling
in all these second tier like requests, so
to speak?"
And they say "Yeah, hypothetically, if you
had an extra day, we probably have a lot more
to work with."
I said, "Okay, let me think about it.
I got it.
Wednesday nights.
You were right.
But the hours are different.
From 10:00 p.m. till 2:00 a.m."
Tim Ferriss: Oh, gosh.
Aryeh Bourkoff: From year one of the company,
I will do office hours.
But no internal bitch sessions.
There's no suggestion box.
This is an external session.
If people really want it that bad, I'll be
here.
No one else internally has to be here.
Just leave me a little food, a little drink,
and let's see who wants to be here.
I'll be here and then I'll start the next
day at the same time, seven in the morning,
eight in the morning, whatever.
I'll eat it on my end for year and I think
it'll unclog the situation.
And we've created what you viewed as a constraint
of time.
I created time by eating into my sleep hours.
So your 4-Hour Workweek is really a four-hour
sleep week for me.
But anyway, but it worked.
People showed up for a year till two in the
morning and it was the most interesting, grateful
conversations.
And it's just New York City at its finest.
In the office, you're talking about life and
career and that paid dividends.
Not business dividends, but reputational benefits
and humanity benefits.
Who are you?
What do you want to be at the end of the day?
And I'm happy we did it.
I don't regret for a second.
Now I don't do that now.
I would love for someone else in the company
to do that now because I'm in motion still
and I want to be more selective and deep with
relationships versus volume-oriented right
now.
And I almost want people to compete for the
depth of those relationships with me versus
the masses.
But that's what the firm is supposed to be
to understand what is selective versus, but
the firm needed that at the beginning to really
understand what we're about.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, amazing story.
Wow.
10:00 p.m. to 2:00 a.m.
So two questions.
How did you choose 10:00 p.m. to 2:00 a.m.?
Was that just to separate the casual inquiries
from the true believers?
That's question one.
How did you choose 10:00 p.m. to 2:00 a.m.?
And then the second, you mentioned something
that I think probably caused a number of people
to perk up because it would be the opposite
of what many would perhaps say.
And that is the assistance job is to say yes.
You can always say no.
I think assistance are viewed by many folks
as a protective layer, maybe a flack jacket
to deflect as much incoming as possible.
So I'd love to hear you just explain why 10:00
p.m. to 2:00 a.m. and elaborate on the assistance
job being to find a way to say yes.
Aryeh Bourkoff: Well, 10:00 p.m. to 2:00 a.m.
is easy because I want to leave room for dinner.
Not dinner, God forbid, like a personal dinner.
A client dinner, a dinner outside.
Business and life for me are very well integrated.
So it would be used the city, go to dinner,
and then after dinner I come back.
Some people still bring this up.
People see me on the street, they say, "Aryeh,
are you still doing three dinners a night?"
And I'm like, "That may have happened one
time, maybe 10 times."
But then two times I would do dinner, I would
go to two dinners a night.
I was just try to get it all in and not eat
as much at each dinner and move around.
And probably in retrospect, was it the best
thing to convey to people.
But except for the fact that I was working
hard and try to make sure everyone was happy
and that I would get it all in.
But at this 10:00 to 2:00 was about making
sure that that night I would have room for
my dinner meeting or out of the office, using
New York, great city to do that.
And then came back to the office, enough time
and then starting 10:00 p.m. and then I wanted
to have enough time.
There's this great song, I think it's You
Too song that has a line that says the magic
hours are when it's not yet the morning, but
it's still night, but it's not really nighttime.
And so you haven't yet figured out that it's
morning time.
You haven't started thinking about your next
day yet, but it's past normal nighttime for
everybody else.
So you really can't be bothered.
And none of us really live that way, I think
day to day.
But that must be where a lot of magic happens.
And then you get to a point where you start
thinking, Oh, my gosh, tomorrow morning my
calendar is this and that.
That, to me, starts around two in the morning.
And so if I went past two, I'd start eating
into what I have to start doing the next day.
Yeah, I'll remember the song.
I'll remember the song.
I just listened to the on the internet for
the first time again.
Tim Ferriss: No problem.
Could put in the show notes too.
Aryeh Bourkoff: Yeah, yeah.
That's a great song.
Oh, yeah.
"When the night has no end and the day yet
to begin, when the room spins around, I need
your love."
It's "Hawkmoon Rising," Rattle and Hum.
YouTube on the Rattle and Hum album was the
only place you could find, I think.
Rattle and Hum, YouTube, "Hawkmoon."
Tim Ferriss: Good memory.
Aryeh Bourkoff: There you go.
Tim Ferriss: And the assistant.
Aryeh Bourkoff: The assistant.
The complexity of the job of an assistant,
particularly for me or for anyone in a relationship
business where it's meaningful and there's
a long bill to it and a long tail to it, and
genuinely is probably the most complex, respected
job in the company.
And it is a puzzle piece that is, I always
think of it as those images of broadcast television
when you're like, "Okay, I have Thursday night,
must see TV, and what's going to be the six
o'clock hour?
What's going to be the seven o'clock hour?
What's going to be eight o'clock hour?
And how's one going to lead into the other?
And how's it going to fit in?
Are people going to be still botched at 10
o'clock when it's over?
And what's going to be the show after the
Super Bowl that you promote?"
How the calendar flows and behaves is a living,
breathing animal with a soul and a brain and
everything else.
And the people that have to construct that
every single day, today and into the future.
The assistant, I think is, I respect that
brain power and that knowledge more than anything,
in some cases, including my role.
So if you start with no, instead of yes, then
you've stopped playing the puzzle.
You've said, I can't fit the puzzle piece,
so it's not going to fit somewhere.
But if you say yes, then the puzzle keeps
expanding.
And the calendar has to mimic the strategy
of the firm where I want to be going, the
changes in the development of the firm, the
changes in the people I want to play with,
work with, experience life with.
And the understanding of that has to mimic
one another.
And so it's not, they say yes, I say no.
It is much more of we understand where we're
going and the calendar has to reflect the
vision of what's going on in my head, and
therefore has to be communicated that way.
And then it has to have a yes around it somewhere.
Tim Ferriss: I dig it.
Yeah.
Thematically, makes sense.
I want to hop to UBS here, and-
Aryeh Bourkoff: I'll tell you one more thing
about the calendar, by the way, because I
talk about it a lot.
If you boil it down, internal meetings, everyone
has a ratio.
So if you did nothing because of your reputation
and your brand and your substance, your calendar
is going to be full.
People are going to want to get on your calendar
all the time, without you even choosing who
you want to see.
That's what I call defense.
And if put that aside for a second and then
you had a blank sheet paper and said, "Forget
that calendar.
I, Tim, want to choose exactly who I want
to see."
And that may not fill the whole calendar every
single day, but it'll be proactive, it'll
be offense.
So what's defense and what's offense?
How everyone has to create a balance of those
two things in their calendar.
Who wants to see them and who do you want
to see?
And that mix.
And then there's the internal versus the external.
And there's no way around the fact that internal
meetings are cost or investment.
Doesn't have to be negative, could be, but
they're necessary investments in the company
or cost and external meetings should be revenue
or potentially for future revenue.
So one's revenue, one's cost.
If your calendar is 50/50, offense, defense
or external, internal or revenue, cost, you
haven't done anything.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Aryeh Bourkoff: You're running in place.
And so I'm very cognizant of, "What's the
ratio?
What's the ratio?"
And so I've figured out a lot time I go, I
really would love the ratio to be like 70/30
external versus internal or maybe 80/20.
And then you could start thinking to yourself,
"Okay, well that builds a good margin.
And then you start, and then different times
of the year have different moments.
Obviously if you're paying bonuses, you're
doing reviews, maybe there's a little more
internal, but by and large, the internal should
be more predictable.
If you're managing a good organization, you
could probably put the internal on your calendar
for the entire year.
Otherwise, there's surprises going on.
And if there's more surprises going on, the
less well managed the company is.
So you should be able to pretty much put the
internal on your calendar right now for the
whole year.
And then the external, you'd be surprised
at how much external you can put in your calendar
in advance also.
"I'll meet you at Formula 1 in Austin, Tim.
Do you want to go again this year?"
This is a date, or this conference or this
event or this holiday.
And you could probably put the tent poles
of your external on the calendar.
You'd be surprised how little room that leaves
for the spontaneity and the serendipity of
life, which it must.
So something has to then give absent sleeping
hours.
And so that's what you're playing with.
You're playing with these marginal slivers
of space that is growth, that is a choice,
that is what's different today versus last
year.
And that will represent who you are today
versus last year and what you want to be in
the future.
And whether the best companies in the world
is going to stay exactly where they were or
evolve.
There's no accident that most companies don't
You really have to work at it, a constant
build.
You're dealing with slivers of space and time
to make that happen.
Tim Ferriss: I'm glad you added that.
I'm taking a number of notes for myself, so
that's why I'm scribbling furiously over here.
You mentioned briefly-
Aryeh Bourkoff: I would cancel all internal
meetings for you, by the way.
To see you, I would take my internal meetings
off this.
I would just, on a moment's notice, I would
go fly and see you.
That would be like, that's the sign of true
respect.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, well thank you for saying
that.
And I look forward to the next time we're
able to spend some time in person.
And I'm very much enjoying this entire conversation.
I've been looking forward to this and bonuses.
You mentioned bonuses, and I think this will
tie a number of threads together, some of
which are yet to come, but we're skipping
ahead a bit.
But you ran investment banking, or certainly
you ran investment banking in the Americas
for UBS and had something like 1,500 people
reporting to you.
When people came to you or bankers came to
you, talk to you about annual bonuses, as
I understand it from the Hollywood Reporter
piece, you would ask, "What is your edge?"
And I would love to hear you just elaborate
on the function of that question and what
you mean by that.
Aryeh Bourkoff: It goes back to how you're
judged.
Ideally, you're judging yourself every single
day.
Everyone's making their own adjustments every
single day.
And then you have external factors which remind
you how you're doing, every single day.
And there's a lot of haphazard activity, and
not everything's logic, based on logic and
reason.
But if you're running a business, you'd have
a daily profit and loss statement, which tells
you how you're doing.
If you own a restaurant, tells you what you're
doing, if you run a investment fund, tells
what you're doing, that all those things contribute
to your own humility and self correctness.
If you're paying somebody a bonus or a compensation
at the end of the year, you are the one that's
creating that self-awareness in that person.
I've never seen anybody come into a conversation
around compensation and feel as an employee
that their boss has synced up exactly with
what they think that they're worth.
I've never seen it.
So within that, there's a chasm of misunderstanding
or emotion of what you think you're worth
versus what they think you're worth, on a
given year.
Okay.
And that's normal life.
Ideally, you'd like to have some daily metric
that just defines that, that daily P and L.
So at the end of the year, there's no one
big event.
So what I was trying to do is to try to build
in as much of that narrowing of that chasm
as possible before the conversation because
it is a negotiating strategy, or you could
call it a real effort to just build awareness,
saying...
The best way to do that is to ask someone
to define who they are, you'd be surprised
when you'd ask them to talk about themselves
how passive they will be and either how little
they will value themselves in the right way,
and how much they over-value themselves in
the wrong way.
So I feel like people always say, "What is
your superpower?"
and maybe those things are thrown around too
often these days.
What's your competitive advantage?
What's your edge?
In a certain defined role like the role of
finance or the role of banking, I said, "The
edge really comes into play of do you have
a unique idea, do you bring unique capital,
or do you have a unique relationship?"
But I wouldn't give them the answer.
I was trying to figure out if they could get
to it.
If someone says, "I work harder than everybody
else," okay.
Imagine telling an NFL player or NBA player,
"I work harder."
Is that really an edge these days?
I mean, one of these we hear like, "I'm doing
the best I can," I'm like, "Okay.
Well, then you get out of bed, and then what
happens?"
I'm assuming everyone's doing the best they
can.
Whenever anyone says, "Life is too short,"
I'm like, "Well, life is the longest thing
you know.
You don't know anything longer than life."
So I'm like, "Let's just live it to the fullest
as much as you can."
You know?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah.
Aryeh Bourkoff: But then do better than that.
So when you ask someone to define their edge
or their advantage, they'll learn a lot about
themselves.
Tim Ferriss: So was this conversation then...
It was preceding the official performance
review/decision on the bonus?
This would be a precursor, sort of setting
the table months or weeks or whatever timeframe
prior to the actual conversation?
Aryeh Bourkoff: Yes.
You would see people, and I would rarely even
initiate it, you would see people...
Oh, I had one this morning, today, actually,
and people wanted to get a sense of where
they stand or how they're valued, or what
their opportunity is in the future.
All those are codewords for, "How am I going
to get paid?"
It's fine.
It is what it is.
Again, it would be better for those things
to happen on a day-to-day basis that define
that instead of my...
I mean, well, who am I?
Why am I telling you how you're going to get
paid?
You tell me how you're going to get paid based
on what your edge and what your opportunity
is, and my job is to provide the platform
for you to optimize that better than anywhere
else, and your job is to optimize it here
and have the free market to choose somewhere
else if you can't do that or I can't do that,
and the bet with all of those solutions or
scenarios is maybe some biases or some lack
of self-awareness, or my mistakes of not building
the right platform or not managing correctly.
All right?
So, maybe as a manager my job is really to
throw the penalty flags around versus manage
and tell you exactly what you're worth before
I have to.
One's entrepreneurial and one's needing to
be secure, but where does that security come
from, self, inside, or outside?
When you're a parent to a child, you have
to provide that security, but at some point
they have to then get unlocked.
So I just think it's about not everyone has
to be entrepreneurial all the way, but there
are certain responsibilities that I have to
build the business for people to thrive and
make sure it's that kind of environment, mission-driven
and opportunistic and a meritocracy around
that, and certain responsibilities that people
have within it to then take it competitively
better than the best they can, and the risk
I take is that they could do it somewhere
else better than here.
But I own that risk every single day.
What risk do they own?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Yeah.
Well said.
So, for people listening, I want to add a
bit of color and then ask about a specific
instance.
So, you have been part of and a driving force
behind some of the largest deals the world
has ever seen, certainly in media, and people
might be listening and thinking, "My god.
This guy doesn't sleep.
He has endless energy.
It's just a home run every time he steps up
to the plate," which may in part be true,
but could you please...
I'm going to get the name wrong.
I don't know how to pronounce this properly,
but can you please tell the deck of cards
story with Joe Ianniello?
Is that how you say that name correctly?
Aryeh Bourkoff: Ianniello.
Tim Ferriss: I knew I wasn't going to get
that right.
All right.
Aryeh Bourkoff: The fact that you got my name
right and not Joe's is a real sign of growth
in the industry.
I appreciate it.
Well, obviously, what appears to be a home
run every time is not.
I mean, first of all, every day is full of
happiness and successes and frustrations and
consternations and irritations about what
we could be doing better, what I could be
doing better, frankly, all the time.
I do try to...
I'm as much an introvert as I am an extrovert,
by the way.
I think the biggest misnomer is I'm always
out and about.
I get a lot of energy from being out and about
partially because of other people's energy,
not just my own, but I also really enjoy some
thinking time with music and some reading
time, and kind of a chance to reenergize and
go deeper than just bouncing around, and that
you just don't Instagram out the periods we're
you're sitting alone.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Aryeh Bourkoff: So people only see you do
the things that you're like where you're bouncing
around.
They don't see the moments where you're just
happily sitting alone or reading a book or
listening, unless you're really not focusing
on it.
You know?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Aryeh Bourkoff: So I think the appearances
are a bit misleading, but it's the texture
of all of the above, and some of that thoughtfulness
is where you really come into strategizing
around what the future could be for you, for
your loved ones, and also for the deal making
in the future.
But in that particular story, it all goes
back to this element of what you know, what
you don't know, and we were doing a deal,
I think in 2007, for a company called Sundance
Channel, which was owned by NBC, CBS, and
Robert Redford, and we were selling the company
on behalf of the owners.
I was at UBS, and we really did a good job,
I have to say.
We did a good job selling the company.
It was not an easy sale.
Eventually, the Dolans bought it, actually.
The company that owned IFC, Cablevision, and
the Knicks bought the Sundance Channel for
$500 million.
I thought we did a good job, and I remember
in those days, and in some cases also today,
when the job is done, then you start to think
about, "Well, how much am I going to be paid
for the services?"
Now, sometimes you can get that figured out
at the beginning.
In this case, you figure it out at the end.
We were thinking that would work to our benefit
because it was such a home run deal, and I
thought we did such a good job that they would
want to pay us more, whereas if we agreed
at the beginning, we probably would've undersold
ourselves.
Robert Redford did really well in that deal,
I remember.
I think he probably made more money in that
deal than all of his acting years combined,
but he was a pleasure to work with.
But CBS's CFO, or I think it was the treasurer
at the time, was Joe Ianniello.
He rose through the rank of even being the
CEO for a while after that, and Joe was a
tough negotiator, but we were on the same
side of the table.
So, afterwards I was told by my bosses at
UBS, "Okay, Aryeh, great job on the deal.
Now go get us a good fee," and I said, "Okay.
I have to do that too?
All right."
He said, "Yeah, yeah.
That's what it takes," and I said, "Okay."
So, I went over to...
Joe was appointed as a person that had to
negotiate our fee, and I thought it would
be like one of these great kumbaya conversations,
we all did a great job together, and let's
have drinks and get this settled quickly,
but no.
So I went over to what they call Black Rock,
the CBS building, and it was this long conference
room, and it was just Joe and myself sitting
in the middle, and Joe said, "Hey, you're
here to negotiate your fee, right?"
and I said, "Yeah."
You project some confidence, but you're really
nervous inside, and he said, "Just to break
the ice a little bit before we get into that
negotiation, do you want to play some cards?
Do you want to do a card trick?
I'm getting into cards recently."
That sounds great.
We're friends now too?
This is great.
Amazing.
So, he said, "In fact, you know what?
More than just a card trick, why don't we
just shortcut the whole thing since you're
busy, I'm busy, and why don't you just pick
out of the deck any card, and whatever card
you pick will be your fee, and we'll just
do it by chance."
I said, "Really?
We'll do that?"
I said, "Just to clarify, a face card with
a jack, queen, and king, that'd be like $10
million?" and he said, "Yeah, that's right.
Sold the company for 500 million.
Whatever you pick, that'll be your fee."
I said, "Okay."
So, I reach in, I pull a card out, and it's
a three, and he saw my face, that I was very
disappointed.
He said, "You seem dejected.
Would you like to do it again?"
I said, "Well, yeah.
Can I do it again?"
and he said, "Yeah, let's do best out of three."
So, I said, "Great."
I'm like, "So nice, gracious."
I do it again and I pick out a three again,
and I'm thinking, "No, this is terrible."
Now, I don't remember exactly what I was expecting
to get, but definitely more than a three,
and definitely relative to the face cards
or anything else I was thinking, this was
towards the bottom of the deck.
So, he goes, "You seem like you're in a bit
of a stuck place.
Maybe you want to call the home office back
at UBS and find out what they have to say."
I go, "Yeah.
I have to do that.
I can't just walk back with that."
He goes, "You can use the phone on the couch
over here.
Just sit in the corner."
So I went to the phone, picked up the handset,
and there was a card on the handset, and it
was face down.
I picked it up and I turned it over, and it
was a three.
By that point, I had realized what was happening.
I put the phone down —
Tim Ferriss: You were negotiating with David
Blaine.
Aryeh Bourkoff: I said, "Are you telling me,
Joe, that our fee is $3 million?"
He goes, "That's what I'm telling you."
He had the whole thing wired.
So I respected it.
That's what we got.
That's what we took.
Tim Ferriss: So negotiating is one of your
sports in the sort of decathlon of dealmaking
that is the craft, one of the crafts you've
mastered.
This is going to seem like a lazy question,
but I'm going to ask because it'll be on the
mind of a lot of people listening.
For someone who wanted to become a skilled
negotiator, would you have any recommendations
in terms of resources, approaches, common
beliefs that are actually very unhelpful,
anything at all for somebody who wants to
develop their ability to negotiate well?
Aryeh Bourkoff: Yeah, of course.
As probably the opposite of what people will
believe or instinctively would do, which is
usually the answer, by the way, I would say
90 percent of the time everyone focused on
what is important to them and what we or what
you say.
It's irrelevant.
All that matters is how it lands to the other
person.
It's life.
In order to understand how something will
land to the other person, you have to meet
them where they are.
You have to put yourself in their shoes.
Once you put yourself in someone else's shoes,
then you don't have to do what they say in
a negotiation, but you have to at least start
with that understanding, and then go back
to what's most important to you from there,
and then you have a fair understanding of
what that negotiation is going to look like.
But if you just start throwing your words
against the wall, it's never going to end
well, and you're going to be very frustrated,
and there'll be temper tantrums, and so on.
I kind of make it...
The best analogy I can think of is when you
are in huddle, about to throw at pass at a
football game, and you have figured out you're
going to throw a post pattern in the huddle,
and you thought about in that huddle.
If you say "Hike," play goes, and you throw
the post pattern on play, but you haven't
looked at actually what happened in the field,
and the receiver had to go in a different
direction, you need to meet that receiver
where they are.
Your post pattern play is irrelevant.
It's only relevant to your formation at the
beginning, but it's not relevant to actually
where the ball is going to go in the end,
because what happened on the field is much
more important.
So, you have to do the preparation work.
You have to have a sense of what you think
is proper and right from your perspective,
but you also have to understand what will
be the scenarios that will be important to
them, and then the middle ground approach
is too often used.
It's not that.
It's just starting from understanding both
vantage points.
It's the same kind of skill set as saying
before I put a buy on something, I have to
also reject the sell.
You have to be comfortable in an unknown position
before you can adequately argue for what's
important to you.
Then in a trusted relationship, which is the
only way to negotiate, in a trusted relationship,
you're going to get down to things that are
really important and things that are not really
that important, and to be able to be comfortable
saying that...
Okay.
If I listed these three things, please rank
in order for me what's most important to you
and what you really don't need, that would
give me a little bit more room to come back
to you with something that I think we can
work with, because that shows that you'll
be willing to give up something to get something,
which is obviously a hallmark in any transaction.
Now that's a good negotiation.
There are tactics above that.
So, sometimes in order to get to somewhere
that you need, you may ask for things that
you don't really want just to settle back
into something that is a discount to that,
that you only would do that if you feel like
the other person's doing the same thing.
So it all goes back to trust, and that trust
is not about one person trusting another.
It's the different phases of the negotiation
that trust picks up.
So, at the beginning of a negotiation, it
may be less trustworthy than at the end when
things are really coming to the finish line,
when you can see the light of day.
Then things start to pick up towards the trust.
So, you have to see when you can play with
different tactics, but at the end of the day,
it's seeing people where they are, I think
is really, really important, without giving
up what you really need.
Tim Ferriss: So let's explore that a bit.
So, seeing people where they are, you gave
the football metaphor.
Could you describe an actual deal situation
or process?
It could be real.
It could be anonymized.
It could be hypothetical, but just to walk
us through a concrete case study of what that
looks like, knowing the other side, since
you led with that in your answer.
Could you perhaps just walk us through an
example?
Aryeh Bourkoff: Yeah.
I will, actually.
I think all the deals that we work on that
are public, company deals, end up being filed
publicly with the play-by-play of the deal.
No one likes to read legal documents, but
the fun part of the legal document is the
play-by-play of the deal if people are interested
in the step-by-step of how a deal works, because
while we're doing the deal, we're very aware
of the fact that it will be filed publicly.
So, it's not like you're pulling fast ones
because it's going to be disclosed, how you're
doing what you're doing.
So, you have to be truthful.
There's no concept of lying in a deal because
it will all be uncovered later, if you want
to be in the business the next day.
So that's called a proxy statement, and that
one section is written up by lawyers that
actually recount the deal.
Tim Ferriss: Did not know that.
Aryeh Bourkoff: Yeah.
So, what I'm going to say is public information.
When we did the transaction of selling MGM
Studios to Amazon, which is the only example
of a content company being sold to a technology
company to date, there was an impasse between
the buyer and the seller that went on for
a while.
The deal ended up being worth around $8.5
billion, but for months Amazon would not go
above eight billion, and MGM and the owners
of MGM decided, "We are not selling below
$9 billion, hell or high water."
So we were at an eight-to-nine-billion-dollar
bid ask for months, to the point where the
deal could've gone away.
On the one hand you're close, on the other
hand, nothing's happening.
So, finally, the chairman on MGM who was a
really dear friend calls me and says, "I'm
ready to...
What do you think?
I'm ready to unlock this gap," and I knew
Amazon very well, enough to know that they
were thinking because of this gap was going
on for so long that the owner of MGM and the
chairman, in their mind, they were thinking
didn't really want to sell.
So they were thinking that nine billion was
just basically saying, "I don't really want
to sell."
Of course, I knew that was not to be the case.
So the owner and chairman of MGM said to me,
"I give you, my proxy, to go in there and
break the log jam."
So I did, and when I went to call the Amazon
executives, I said, "Okay.
We're ready to negotiate now," and they said,
"Well, there's nothing to negotiate.
They're at nine billion, and we're at eight
billion, and we're not moving."
I said, "Okay."
They said, "They're not even really interested
in selling the company."
I said, "Well, what if I told you that they
were selling the company?"
He said, "Well, how would I know?"
I said, "Well, I'll, in good faith, speak
on behalf of the chairman, and I give you
a new offer that will yield a bit, under the
condition that you get back to me with a counteroffer
right away, within 24 to 48 hours, so I get
also the feedback back to the chairman that
you're serious about dealings, meaning that
if I could speak for a principal, you have
to speak also that you want to get something
done, but I'm not going to move unless you're
going to move, and I need know that you're
going to move."
That was trust because they took a risk that
I could represent the owners of MGM.
They said, "Okay.
What do you got?" and I said, "I think we
should split the difference and go right to
it, but it has to go fast, and you have to
get back to me right away," and they did.
If they didn't...
In those 48 hours, there was a lot of emotion,
but they did get back, and it moved very,
very fast from there.
So that's exactly what we're talking about.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Well, someday I look forward to reading your
compendium of deal stories.
I would be the first in line to buy a copy
of that.
But before we get to the compendium of deal
stories, probably a better title to be had,
you mentioned a while back reading time, and
there are quite a few books recommended in
your year-end letter.
Are there any particular books that come to
mind that have impacted your thinking recently,
in the last few years, or any, let's just
say timeless books, perennial books that have
impacted your thinking?
Aryeh Bourkoff: Yeah.
There are quite a few.
I mean, I probably buy more books than I read.
I wonder if that's the case for a lot of people,
actually.
I listen to more books than I read.
I don't read complete books, but I do try
to read as much as I can.
So I would say the timeless books are, one
we'll call Leadership and Self-Deception.
It's really a book about self-awareness that
we really handed out to the firm, and it's
a book about really just owning your own decisions.
That's a timeless book.
Tim Ferriss: And the title was Leadership
and Self-Deception?
Aryeh Bourkoff: Yeah, Leadership and Self-Deception.
The other two timeless books are a book called
Scale by Geoffrey West that is all about why
some things last minutes.
Humans could go on for 70, 80 years.
The Queen lasted 96 years.
The average public company goes for 10, 10-and-a-half
years, and then dies, but cities seemingly
last forever.
You can throw nuclear bombs at cities, unfortunately,
but they still keep moving.
Why do some things last finite periods of
time, and some things last much longer?
It's all about what you feed it and the ability
to grow it, but ultimately, it goes back to
adaptability.
If something has a rigid purpose and you break
the purpose, it will die.
Profits for a company will die.
A city, the people always reinvent itself.
This summer, I think five governments fell
this summer, the UK, you had Italy, you had
Israel, you had Sweden recently, and you have
even France became dysfunctional, and I was
like, "Oh, my goodness.
All these governments are falling, but that's
okay because if the people are unhappy and
the governments don't fall, that's rigid.
That's a problem."
If governments fall, it's a chance for reinvention,
and just like New York City where I'm sitting
now had a chance to reinvent itself post-pandemic,
or in Detroit, a company town, when the industry
falters in the auto industry, it had a chance
to reinvent itself with creativity, or Medellín
in Colombia, it used to be known as a rough
drug trade town.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, murder capital of the world
during Escobar's rule.
Yeah.
Aryeh Bourkoff: Yeah.
That was cool.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Aryeh Bourkoff: Technology hub, artsy.
Cities reinvent themselves, basically adaptable,
forcing function of those people.
I love that.
It's very helpful for a company build dynamic.
The third one is a book called Scarcity.
I think we're moving from a period of abundance
to scarcity.
So how you are not fearful of scarcity, but
how you could do more with less, and we're
getting into a period now where unfortunately,
there's scarcity of food and water and energy
resources, shortages because of macroeconomic
dynamics, warfare in the Ukraine and Russia,
and I think inequality post-pandemic and how
you deal with scarce resources, people paying
their bills plus inflation, what you do out
of those dynamics, it creates a lot of tension
and fear and conflict, even military conflict.
It's a different kind of read than Abundance,
and we have everything we want.
But then the books I read now more recently
are about people.
I'm reading a book now called A Banker's Journey
about Edmond Safra's journey, a banker from
Brazil.
It just came out.
I'm reading a book now by Chris Blackwell
about the music industry and his forming in
the music industry and founding Bob Marley
and U2, and his journey, things that are interesting,
personal stories.
I read books all the time.
Jann Wenner just came out with a book today
I'm looking forward to buying, the Rolling
Stone editor and founder.
He and his son Gus are friends, his son more
than Jann.
But interesting life stories, texture to read.
I like to read a lot and I probably read more
than I consume other forms of media.
Tim Ferriss: So related to the books, any
biographies that really stick out for you?
And then second, if you read any fiction,
which is not a judgment question, but if you
read any fiction, if there are any fiction
books that have had an outsized impact on
you in any way?
Aryeh Bourkoff: Biographies?
I like all the Niall Ferguson books.
I read The House of Rothschild, the J.P. Morgan
books.
I actually read Bill Cohan's book on the Lazard,
Last Tycoons.
Really good book.
That's not only because of being in this business,
but you do want to go back to the underpinnings
of what is relationship banking.
I really think that's a really interesting
profession beyond just finance.
It's how to build with people over a long
period of time, I think, with outsized impact.
I think that's really, really interesting
to me and I hope other people in the firm
and even your listenership.
And fiction?
I've always loved some of the mystery novels,
the legal thrillers.
I've always liked the John Grisham books.
But I would say meaningful to me?
Ayn Rand, obviously it's not fiction per se.
John Steinbeck, The Pearl, a recommendation
of a friend of mine who's in the business.
I reread the other day, great book.
And I love The Sun Also Rises, Hemingway.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, great book.
Aryeh Bourkoff: There's a particular line
in there that I love, at least if we're talking
about bankruptcy, saying that it happens gradually
and then suddenly.
Sometimes things on the way up happen to feel
very slow and methodical, but on the way down,
things happen gradually and then suddenly.
There's not a symmetric relationship between
things that happen on the way up and things
that happen on the way down.
And then another book I would say is David
Brooks' The Second Mountain.
It's a really interesting book.
I view it as a book about personal development,
careers, people in our age of life.
You kind of start your career coming out of
school and thinking about what you want to
do, one step in front of the other.
And then you get to a certain point at our
stage of life and then you say, "Well that's
where I started from to where I am.
It has nothing really to do with where I want
to end up, top of the second mountain."
And once you start thinking about that, you
end up in the valley of thought until you
figure out where that second mountain is.
And when you start climbing the second mountain,
you don't even have to get to the destination.
It's just a joyful climb.
It's a happy climb.
You're doing every single thing you want to
do with every breath you have.
I love that whole concept, finding that second
mountain.
There's no such thing as a linear move from
the day you come out of school all the way
until you die.
It's not linear.
You're going to hit a chasm and it's cool
until you find that second mountain to climb
personally, professionally, et cetera.
It's all good.
Tim Ferriss: I'm going to buy that today.
I also love John Steinbeck and I've read pitifully
little of his work, but Travels with Charley,
if anyone has not read that nonfiction account
of him traveling across the United States
with his dog, it is absolutely laugh-out-loud
hilarious, and also very profound in its hilarious
observations.
But David Brooks, I'm going to get that book
today.
Thank you for the recommendation.
I must ask a question to scratch my own itch
in terms of curiosity, and this is related
to one of your more recent investments.
You've invested in Malcolm Gladwell's audio
production company, Pushkin Industries, per
your 2021 year end letter.
I'm a huge fan of Malcolm.
He's been on the podcast, huge fan of Michael
Lewis also who's been involved with Pushkin
and who's also been on the podcast.
The caliber and quality of what they produce
is I think absolutely astonishing.
What do you think is next for the podcast
market?
Or if you have any thoughts on where you think
things are going, what trends are emerging
or converging?
What do you see coming over the next handful
of years for the podcast market or industry?
Aryeh Bourkoff: The audio market and the podcast
market is strong and growing.
Clearly, like everything in content, the quality
has to rise to the top because a lot of people
have jumped into it and have to also get curated
in terms of guides.
Remember at the beginning of YouTube you were
in the jungle, you had no idea how to navigate
YouTube.
Now finally you could, if you want to go to
sports you know where to go.
And if you want to go to history, if you want
to go to brands, commerce, you know where
to go.
So I think there needs to be more curation
around audio and podcasting in general, where
you find different content and when, how you
digest highlights versus the whole episodes,
et cetera.
But if it's going to be more branded and more
curated I think from here.
And heavily monetized, but hopefully not over-monetized
in ways that are uncomfortable.
I'm not anticipating things that are full
advertisements, but sponsorship is going to
be more interesting.
Platforms that will really get behind it.
Obviously iHeart, Spotify, Amazon, but every
platform that reaches a global audience needs
differentiated content today.
Video content alone has hit diminishing returns.
Audio content and podcasting content, I think,
that's really well-branded and curated and
quality like this one, I think the best is
yet to come still.
And it hasn't even stretched service globally.
So I think those are going to be really interesting.
But I think more curated, more guides, more
branded content and monetized in different
ways I think will be pretty important.
And then there's social features as well,
some more interactivity of being able to do
events and tours and going around to talk
to your audiences and having more of an interaction
between the fans and the creators I think
is a big wide space.
Tim Ferriss: And do you have any thoughts
on how the market will move or consolidate?
Because I've watched all this with great interest
of course, and I've looked at certain transactions,
say relatively speaking, heavy spending.
And I will just underscore something you said,
which is, I think it's still very early.
If you look at the terrestrial radio, total
ad dollars compared to what has currently
migrated to say podcast, it is still just
the tip of the iceberg.
And even when I launched this podcast in,
I can't even recall what it was, 2014, 2016,
I was told by folks the ship has sailed, it's
too late, there are too many podcasts.
I just don't think that's the case at all.
Aryeh Bourkoff: I was told the same thing
when we launched the bank in 2012, that it
was late to start a new independent bank,
that ship has sailed.
And I was like, "Well, maybe the door will
shut behind us, we'll be the last one."
Tim Ferriss: Seems it seems to be working
out in both cases.
And if I pick one player, for instance, let's
just say Spotify spending very heavily with
respect to just their market cap and moving
into podcasts, the Joe Rogan deal valued at
least a 100 million, probably quite a bit
more with earnouts and everything else, my
assumption has always been that once Spotify
accounts for more than single-digit listenership
or downloads or streams for the top, say 100
podcasts which will be reflective of broader
trends, that that type of talent acquisition
would drop quite significantly.
Just as one sort of hypothesis.
But what do you think the movements will be
amongst some of the larger players?
Because you have Amazon, you have Spotify,
you have iHeart and podcasts are an existential
imperative perhaps or viewed that way for
some and not others.
What do you think the landscape of the larger
players will look like a few years from now?
Aryeh Bourkoff: Look, I think it took some
of the streaming platforms like Netflix and
Amazon and Apple a long time to get into sports,
for example.
And now they're all bidding for sports rights
because they have to have sports as a differentiator.
And once one gets in, they're all in.
So Amazon is bidding for sports rights, Apple
just did the MLS deal, and they're all looking
at sports.
Netflix has Formula 1: Drive to Survive, right?
In some ways, I think podcasting is the same
thing.
Now that it's hitting the sweet spot of the
curve from a revenue and profitability contribution
for iHeart, that was all over Spotify's investor
day of the podcasting growth driver.
Then you're going to see Amazon and all of
them jump into it and then you may see competition
for talent between platforms and then you
may start to see some of the podcasting personalities
and brands intersect with other genres.
So imagine you're with Amazon and Amazon's
doing the NFL and they want your post-game
show intersected with your podcast of the
NFL.
So they're going to start using you as a key
brand for the platform overall beyond just
the show.
So I think that these becomes assets of the
platform that become very interesting and
different packaging of the deals I think will
be fascinating.
It all depends on the loyalty and engagement
of your user base and your community and what
the community is going to be driving that
they want to see and obviously your ability
to engage with them.
Tim Ferriss: I hadn't thought about the cross-asset
utilization of podcast personalities, but
that makes all the sense in the world and
I have to imagine that's playing into negotiations
right now for talent deals because they might
say, "Well, what's the size of your advertising
base?
Will your sponsors transfer over to us if
we acquire exclusive license or if we acquire
you outright?"
Or whatever it might be, but in fact the value
of that property in terms of the personality
may be much greater when it's viewed as being
possibly applied to all these various things.
This is pure speculation, not investment advice,
obviously, but I think Twitch is going to
prove to be increasingly valuable to Amazon.
And I recall when the pandemic hit, I had
an ongoing bet of sorts with a friend of mine
that we would see some type of platform utilization
for streaming sports if sports could not be
attended in person.
And I just think these off-label uses of these
technology platforms and cross-asset utilization
of personalities, I hadn't thought about that,
makes a whole lot of sense.
Aryeh Bourkoff: You and I met at Formula 1,
so imagine maybe that's in your future where
you're taking on a British accent, doing the
Formula 1 car, I know you're friends with
Lewis and I think there could be that in your
future.
But what do you want, if you were going to
migrate and take and evolve your audience
into a different genre with you, what do you
think that they would be into?
Tim Ferriss: That's a great question.
I haven't really thought of it in this way.
I would imagine, and this will seem very simplistic,
but whatever I am interested in, I think my
audience will trust me to take a very close
look at, or a meaningful percentage of my
audience will trust me to look at, which is
by design largely, that's why I did a book
on physical and sports performance after The
4-Hour Workweek rather than doing The 3-Hour
Workweek, is I wanted to see early on, since
I had this open option to always extend the
business book side of things, if my audience,
much like say with a Michael Lewis, even though
he's a far superior writer, or John McPhee,
or Malcolm Gladwell, would they follow me
because of my approach and thinking, not because
of the subject matter?
And I think by and large that has held since
then.
So it would be a matter of me determining
what I am legitimately interested in because
without that legitimate interest, I won't
have the endurance, I won't have the necessary
emotional investment and endurance to make
it count in any meaningful way, if that makes
sense.
Aryeh Bourkoff: Well yeah, I think that your
whole community is built on trust.
You also have a curiosity to you as well,
but based on certain foundations that people
view you as dependable.
They don't think you're going to veer them
off to an extreme position, but you're inquisitive
about where the world's going.
And my view is that you're ultimately interested
in an impact around that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I am.
Aryeh Bourkoff: But not in an establishment
sort of way.
There's this sort of insurgency around it,
right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Aryeh Bourkoff: I think we're very similar.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I do too.
I was just thinking about this trust and how
its asymmetrical rise, decline, the precipitous
drop, how it takes 20 years to build a reputation
and 20 minutes to destroy it if you make the
wrong choices.
So I say no.
The vetting process for, say, sponsors and
guests and so on is very, very...
I don't want to say strict, it's not quite
the right word, but I always try to ensure
that I'm following my own rules and not getting
swept away by the winds of trend or more specifically
fads.
This may seem like a non sequitur, and it
will be probably one of the last questions,
so hopefully we can do a round two sometimes,
because I have a lot of questions that I would
still love to explore, but this may seem like
an odd segue, but maybe it makes sense in
some way.
You were known as a goalkeeper at UBS, protecting
the balance sheet.
You saved them hundreds of millions of dollars.
And I'm reading here just a snippet from the
piece in The Hollywood Reporter.
Your job was to analyze potential deals and
advise the bankers on whether they made sense.
"In that role, he rejected 40 out of 45 potential
deals."
And this is my words now, didn't make everybody
super thrilled.
"However, when all 40 companies later went
bankrupt, they realized, the higher ups, that
you'd saved hundreds of millions of dollars."
What were you doing there?
You seem to have a certain, I don't want to
say prescience, but an ability to see where
the puck was going with respect to the 40
that were rejected.
How did you do that?
Why did you do that?
Aryeh Bourkoff: First of all, I was a goalkeeper
in high school.
Even as a relatively short person, I was able
to play goalie in soccer.
I think that it all comes down to understanding
there'll be many more shots on goal than exists
today.
So don't be afraid to say no to something
today with a fear that nothing's going to
come tomorrow.
The sample set that you're dealing with today
is not the whole thing and play the long game.
And so I felt that a lot of the companies
that we were looking at at that time were
coming to us because of negative selection,
that we were getting pitched by companies
that weren't necessarily the highest quality.
But just because we had capital doesn't mean
that we should do it.
I wanted to play quality.
I wanted to only do business with the best
companies and if we didn't have the structure
in place to attract those best companies today,
that's our issue to deal with.
But the worst thing you could do to compound
that is make bad decisions on top of fixing
your own structural issues.
And that governs everything even today.
When you're building the company, when you're
working with the outside world, the internal
world, you're making sure that you're making
the right decisions with a quality standard
for excellence at all times and that you're
not accepting mediocrity, especially if those
things have a lot to do with your own fixes
that you have to make.
So we spend a lot of time doing infrastructure
work internally and then planning for excellence.
But if you're going to do one thing, I prefer
inactivity than mediocrity.
I want to make sure that we play for excellence
and quality all the time, all the way through
the company and all the way through the ripple
effects we have externally, and do fewer things
with quality than scale things, obviously.
Ultimately, prefer to do a lot of quality
things, but that takes a lot of structure.
That's what I call scaled intimacy.
If you can scale the constant of intimate
relationships and intimate deal making, that's
the panacea.
But otherwise, I prefer to do just a few high
quality things and then take it easy for a
while.
But I think that's the standard.
Don't settle that.
But I do have to tell you one story, though,
because you did give me some really interesting
prep work.
Tim Ferriss: Yes, please.
Aryeh Bourkoff: Your prep work had questions
on it about certain things, "What's one of
the things that you purchased for less than
a $100 that made a big impact?"
And I would've said a book, so we talked about
some of these books.
But you also said, "Anything particularly
interesting that you've ever had to eat or
drink in your life?"
I thought about it for a few minutes.
I travel the world in interesting places and
you try to integrate business and life and
enjoy what you're doing and appreciate the
finer things where you can.
There is a drink that is served at The Hemingway
Bar at the Ritz Hotel in Paris that is called
the Mach2, M-A-C-H-2.
I've never had it anywhere else.
It's a whiskey-based drink with chartreuse
and the essence of ginger and some ice.
It's really, really good.
But the funny thing about it is, as I was
thinking about it yesterday and thinking I
was going to be talking to you on the podcast,
I last night went to an event in New York
for the Ritz in Paris and Frame was part of
the fashion week.
I was invited to because some friends were
putting it on.
Unexpectedly, that bartender from the Hemingway
Bar in Paris at the Ritz was at the event.
And I said, "It's unbelievable.
I'm going on the Tim Ferriss podcast and he's
going to ask me about a drink and only you
serve this drink in the whole world.
And here you are in New York leaving your
perch at Hemingway Bar.
Could you indulge me with this Mach2 drink?"
He did yesterday.
Tim Ferriss: That's wild.
Aryeh Bourkoff: It all came together.
This is how there's certain karma to my calendar
and this podcast and everything else and your
questions, so I wanted to make sure that we
talked about it.
Tim Ferriss: Wow, that is incredible.
That's synchronicity.
Now I have to try the Mach2.
I look forward to that.
I've needed a reason to...
I've only been to Paris once really in any
meaningful way, so I need to get back.
Side note, because this took place in Paris
for me, I did a lot of writing.
I've done almost all of my writing for my
first three books during those witching hours.
Before the morning and after the usual night,
almost all my writing was done in that I would
say 10:00 p.m. to 3:00 a.m. period.
Almost all of my writing in those witching
hours.
Aryeh Bourkoff: Is that when there are fewer
distractions or you're clear-headed?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
No distractions.
No distractions, more energy.
I tend to be like a hamster.
I just have a second wind that for whatever
reason for my entire life has started very,
very late.
Freedom from distractions, silence, less compulsivity
to interact or text or check anything because
I know the rest of the world is asleep.
I shouldn't say the rest of the world, but
the rest of my network is largely asleep and
it's just always been that twilight, that
creative twilight through which you can perhaps
pull on threads that are normally harder to
access.
I think for me that's been my experience.
Well, Aryeh, I could keep going for hours.
I've got plenty.
So maybe another time, but is there anything
you would like to add, any recommendations
or requests of the audience, things you'd
like to point their attention to?
Of course people can find LionTree at liontree.com.
We'll link to all of the Instagram handles
and social handles in the show notes so people
will be able to access those.
But are there any closing comments or requests
you would like to make before we wind to a
close?
Aryeh Bourkoff: It's been a great pleasure,
Tim.
I could also talk to you for hours.
I was looking forward to this for a long time.
As we go through different periods of time
in our lives and the world at large, and we've
all been through different unexpected movements
and motions and things.
And that's one concept, there's going to be
more unexpected things to come.
It's all about these trusted friends and communities
that we can build, which is the distinguishing
feature of humans, that we can bond together
for good things and tackle the world.
I think if we eliminate all the extremism,
then everyone can redefine their view of what
their centers look like and then that's where
the richness lies.
And whether you find it in the magic hours
in the wee hours of the night or the middle
of the day, I think we can form these circles
and then really bond together, and I think
the best is yet to come.
I really appreciate this relationship and
what we can do together.
And I really appreciate the attention of all
of your audience.
And the one thing about media that is defined
is it's the distribution of content over a
technology.
And when you think of it that way, the technology
used to be books, newspapers, now it's podcasting.
It could be different things in the future,
but the best content distributed is something
that applies to everything in life that people
consume and digest, whether it's music or
words of wisdom or politics, and the responsibility
is on all of us to make the best impact out
of it all and I really appreciate what this
media can do for our lives.
So best is yet to come.
Tim Ferriss: Perfect place to close.
So Aryeh, thank you so much for all your time
and for your wisdom and for your stories.
I have copious notes of my own, so I'll be
following up on a lot after this conversation
personally and really love what you're doing.
And the more I read and learn of you directly
or indirectly, the more questions I have.
So I look forward to future conversations
and for everybody listening, we'll have links
to all resources, names, books, everything
related to Aryeh and LionTree in the show
notes as per usual at tim.blog/podcast.
And until next time, please be safe, be just
a little bit kinder than necessary and find
your center.